[Musik]
dynamisch war graf marcus und ich darf
euch heute der b 110 haye
glanzvorstellung gut man sich das für
ein fahrzeug dieser minen und splitter
geschütztes transportfahrzeug für gerät
und personen auf straßen beziehungsweise
im gelände zum fahrzeug selber das
fahrzeug ist bei mehreren armen weltweit
eingeführt jedoch so wie es der stadt
ist es die modernste ausbaustufe was vor
dem fahrzeug gibt das bundesheer hat 32
stück eingeführt mit einem
investitionsvolumen von zirka 85
millionen euro und die fahrzeuge sind
dann die sechste gebirgszüge
ausgeliefert worden davon hat das
jägerbataillon 23 24 26 und pionier
batterie und zu jeweils acht stück von
diesen fahrzeugen bekommen
dort schauen wir uns aber technische
daten zum fahrzeug an dem fahrzeug ist
verbaut
ein sechszylinder dieselmotor mit 280 ps
und damit schaffen eine
höchstgeschwindigkeit von bis zu 65 km/h
die kraft des motors wird auf alle vier
ketten übertragen das mühlengelände
immer optimales vorankommen hand wir
haben mit dem fahrzeug also ein
maximales gewicht von bis zu 16 tonnen
was man erreichen können wenn man über
gräben drüber pfarrer wendt schaffe man
maximal 1,5 meter überschreitet
fähigkeit beziehungsweise wenn man
steigungen bekanntschaft 31 grad
steigung dass man sich das ein bisschen
vorstellen kann
das ist ein stück steigern oder bisschen
steigern nach wie die motorhaube
was man jetzt da vorne am fahrzeug sehr
nahe das fahrzeug ist für alle
klimazonen was sagen hier auf der welt
gibt einsatztauglich spricht es ist so
konzipiert dass es überall in jedem
einsatz haben auf der welt gerne mal
kann sollte das fahrzeug über weitere
strecken transportieren wollen haben die
möglichkeit dass entweder mit dem
tieflader system zu machen
mit dem transport oder ich hab sogar die
möglichkeit das fahrzeug in die herkules
zum verladen und hat mit dem flugzeug in
den einsatzraum zum befördern wird noch
hat der designer fangen wir beim
rundgang ums fahrzeug an
schauen wir auf der rechten seite vom
fahrzeug was es da alles zusammen ergibt
auf der rechten fahrzeugseite der stelle
was uns einmal ins auge sticht wir haben
da eine gummi kette eine gummiente us
kette ist schon mal die erste
besonderheit was machen
das hat man auf der rechten seite wir
haben nach vorne wo die türe jetzt offen
ist der platz des kommandanten vom
fahrzeug hat die anspruchsvollste
funktion am fahrzeug hat dafür zu sorgen
dass das fahrzeug in den einsatzraum
kommt verbindung mit dem zug zum halten
und er muss gleichzeitig auch alle
funktionen im fahrzeug kennen und können
als er sollte gleichzeitig auch wissen
was der kraftfahrer macht und auch
wissen was der bordschütze macht dafür
hat er da in der türen angebracht und
joystick dass wenn der bordschütze
irgendein problem hat dass er nur
unterstützen kann bzw
über bordschütze darüber arbeiten kann
darunter ist unsere abc anlage horst
sollten atomare biologische oder
chemische kampfstoffe irgendwo um
einander sein kann in die abc anlage
aktivieren und nach hat muss ich eben
fahrzeug drehen keine schutzausrüstung
anziehen da wird einfach ein überdruck
im fahrzeug erzeugt und die luft was in
das fahrzeug hinein gelangt wird
gefiltert und da kann ich ganz normal
meine auftrag im fahrzeug darin weiter
fortführen
noch hat der nächste interessante punkte
oder großes alleinstellungsmerkmal was
dieses fahrzeug hat ist die art der
lenkung wenn man uns das ganze anschauen
das fahrzeug wird gelenkt übers knicken
vom vorderwagen und hinterwagen
gegeneinander also sprich ein
fahrzeugteil alleine im schnitt
einsatztauglich oder kann interessante
ich muss immer das ganze als kombination
herren damals noch vorderwagen und
hinterwagen in der mir das gegeneinander
knick wird einfach er hat das ganze
gelenk das system gut wenn man
weiterschauen toben sie haben danach hat
gleich mal anteile von 2 360 grad und
der kamera
da kommt man auch hat dazu wenn man
hinten den mannschaftsraum anschauen
werde euch das ein bisschen genauer
erklären was es darüber so sehr gut
schauen wir uns einmal an was man da
alles lernen als erstes sticht einmal
ins auge
unser schanz werkzeug sprich sollte
irgendwas sein sollte man es fest fahrer
habe beziehungsweise bande haben haben
wir damals gewisse
ausrüstungsgegenstände dass wir uns
selber wieder austreten könnten nach hat
der rechten seite ist unsere alu leiter
als aufstiegshilfe
dem fahrzeugdach irgendwas erledigen
müssen dass man sicher aufs fahrzeug
aufgekommen und hinten haben wir unsere
anhängekupplung es gibt zudem fahrzeug
auch ein anhänger dazu da hätte man die
anhängekupplung was man einfach ein
anhänger ziehen können
und auf der linken seite ist unsere weil
wände montiert so wie es momentan
montierten transport stellung da habe
ich noch hart wenn diese braucht im
einsatz fall wenn ich selber bergen muss
habe ich zwei möglichkeiten man ist
montieren kann die eine möglichkeit ist
oberhalb von anhängekupplung bzw
haben wir am anfang vorne am fahrzeug
unter dem schutzblech kann jedenfalls
die einwände montieren je nachdem wo
diese gebraucht denn für ein einzelfall
derzeit schauen wir mal in den
mannschaftsraum vom fahrzeuge eine
schauen wir mal den hinter wänden ein
gut sehr schnell was uns da gleich ins
auge sticht ist einmal das 360 grad
kamera system damit kommandant
beziehungsweise der kraftfahrer
jederzeit ziert was passiert habe ich da
die möglichkeit rund ums fahrzeug alles
zu erkennen so dass die mannschaft das
hinten drauf setzt da wissen was
mitkriegt was ausnahme passiert habe ich
natürlich auch im hinterwagen am monitor
nach hat angebrachten wird schauen wir
mal in den hintern wagen hinein schauen
wir mal was es da alles zusammen ergibt
im hinterwagen selber ich habe ja vorher
schon angesprochen dass mira
anhängekupplung draußen hand für was
brauche die das fahrzeug wie am anfang
hab ich meinen geschützt ist horst ich
darf keine ausrüstungsgegenstände
irgendwo am boden liegen aber dass sie
einfach im fall von ammoniten unfall die
gegenstände wo man anfliegen und die
soldaten verletzen oder sogar töten
deswegen habe dahin nur ein relativ
beschränkten raum lernen alle abteile wo
gebäck oder ausrüstungsgegenstände drin
sind müssen geschlossen sein und wenn
ich mir aus richtung mitnehmen muss dann
habe ich halt die möglichkeiten anhänger
dranhängen und kann hat die rechtlichen
ausrüstungsgegenstände was im fahrzeug
selber kaum platz hannah hat auf man
hängen und mit mama genauso dürfen die
füße zum beispiel nicht am boden seien
deswegen gibt es da immer gegenüber die
schlaufen das wirklich alles komplett
von der wandel vom fahrzeug in koppl
tisch das einfach der größtmöglichen
schutz diese für die soldaten herrscht
was sie einmal im hinterwagen daham
anteil der brand unterdrückung anlagen
sollte feuer ausbrechen wird das
automatisch durch die brand
unterdrückung anlage was im fahrzeug
überall verbaut ist sofort wieder
gelöscht
johanna das highlight von unserem
fahrzeug dieser wasserkocher da haben
wir die möglichkeit zu machen bzw wird
zum kochen weil ohne mampf kein kampf
und vor allem im gebirge gilt es das
einfach wenn der soldatisch das hat die
motivation hoch ist und genau deswegen
haben wir uns im wasserkocher drin dass
man selber verpflegen können draussen im
bedarfsfall nach hat gott schauen wir
draußen weiter was draußen alles
zusammen ergibt zimmer auf der linken
seite vom hinterwagen was sie an einmal
da gibt es jetzt nicht unbedingt große
unterschiede zu anderen seite trotzdem
missernte unseren ballistischen schutz
sprich für ihn fand war gegen infanterie
waffen sind geschützt und neuer pass
wasser dem fahrzeug interessant ist wie
habe ich angesprochen dass es
schwimmfähig das ja mal gelbe
markierungen vorne und hinten drauf dass
sich einfach wenn ihm schwimmbetrieb
unterwegs bin
die haben wir die markierungen die
wasserlinie also sprich bis zu den
gelben markierungen liegt das fahrzeug
nach hat im wasser wenn man den
schwimmbetrieb unterwegs sind gut nach
vorne weiter
vorne am fahrzeug hinter der türe
da sitzt der bordschütze mit kleinem
eigenen monitor
da hat danach hat zugriff aufs
kamerasystem das waffenstationen bzw
nach halt auf die waffe was da oben man
türkisch da kommt man dann dazu wenn man
ein fahrzeug nach oben sind und der
letzte punkt was man ein fahrzeug selber
hand danach hat der arbeitsplatz des
kraftfahrers set unser 360 grad kameras
system ebenfalls für den kraftfahrer
wichtig also unterstützung gepanzerte
fahrzeuge ich die runde um sicht relativ
schlecht die scheiben sind klein die
spiele sind relativ klein dass sie zeit
nur begrenzte einstellmöglichkeit
deswegen nicht das wirklich essentiell
dass sie das fahrzeug sicher überall
bewegen kann
das kamerasystem haupt und hat ansonsten
ja der arbeitsplatz ganz normales
lenkrad bzw
unsere armaturen was man einst als
kraftfahrer der die aufgabe hat das
fahrzeug sicher in den einsatzraum zu
bewegen beziehungsweise auch im
einsatzraum nach hat das fazit zum
bewegen wird schauen aus fahrzeug nach
hoffe dass es da oben alles nah zusammen
ergibt das sehr normal da als erstes
einmal unsere elektrisch fernbedienbare
waffenstationen so wie sie jetzt deutsch
mit einem bösen garantiert da haben wir
maximale einsatz schussweite fahren bis
zu 1500 meter und mir hand munition
munitions behälter 300 schuss mit dabei
was kann die waffen station alles wir
haben da eigenes kamerasystem dabei
sowohl mit absicht als auch mit einem
wärmebild gerät zusätzlich an der waffen
station mit dabei haben wir unsere
mehrfach wurfanlage das sind die sechs
tore was man da vorne drauf an
da können wir zb nebel damit fester dass
man uns selber im nebel verstecken
können nach beziehungsweise planen
können was ja noch am fahrzeugdach am
vorderwagen obendrauf mir hand da zwei
schaukästen sprich für
ausrüstungsgegenstände was grösser sind
etwas sperriger sind was im fahrzeug
selber kam platz sandberge gerät oder
zubehör zur waffen station
es ist da am fahrzeugdach am vorderwagen
angebracht gut zimmer am dach vom
hinterwagen angekommen was sehr nah da
alles als erstes der vorne haben wir die
abc anlage von hinterwagen was man haben
oder wagen vorher schon gesprochen hat
ist im hinterwagen am dach angebracht
ebenfalls dass die mannschaft was im
hinterwagen drauf sitzt abc geschützt
ist haben wir diverse staukosten für
zusätzliche ausrüstung und oben auf der
innerstädtischen drauf sind unsere
skiträger nachdem das fahrzeug auch für
das alpine gelände gedacht ich sollte
man mal wirklich einem weiterkommen mit
dem fahrzeug kann die mannschaft
absetzen und sich nachts mit entschieden
weiter bewegen zusätzlich haben wir im
hinterwagen noch auf der rechten seite
unseren abschlepp rahmen verbaut sollte
doch einmal eine panne passieren und wir
müssen uns abschleppen lassen ist da der
abschlepp rahmen mit dabei dass man das
fahrzeug wieder zurück bzw
die flagge auf die kriegen ja hat in dem
bereich und ist die nach fette für das
mg der kanal hat über di luca wurde
gerade drauf sitze außer und nach hat
das fahrzeug nach hinten beziehungsweise
zur seite sichern
gut man hat wir haben es so weit mit dem
rundgang am fahrzeug ist halt nur
geredet schauen wir uns einmal draußen
im gelände an was das fahrzeug an
[Musik]
wenn euch das cover
unter 23 jahren informiert seine
karriere punkte
bisher punkte
[Musik]